what's going on guys welcome back to
geek culture explained my name is rob
and in this video i'm gonna explain to
you guys how it is that i know
why the multiverse is falling apart in
spider-man
no way home so if you guys have seen the
plot leaks and the rumors and all that
kind of good stuff
the multiverse is quite literally
falling apart and that's the reason why
we get andrew garfield spider-man and
toby maguire spider-man and tom holland
spider-man all appearing in the same
movie along with
electro and doctor octopus and the green
goblin from the sony verse now the
question you're probably asking yourself
is
how could this happen how could the
multiverse be falling apart isn't the
multiverse a great big huge place and it
takes a lot of energy and power to make
it happen
yes it does and i think wanda is the
reason behind it but before we get into
that
let's do a little bit of comic book
explanation here let's explain how the
multiverse works in marvel comics and
then let's explain what the marvel
cinematic universe is doing with it
and actually changing it because how
they're handling dormammu is
totally different so the multiverse of
marvel comics is exactly what you would
expect
a combination of universes and there's
actually an infinite number of them most
of them you will never see or hear
anything about but the ones that you do
see
and do hear about have a numerical
designation assigned to them but it
wasn't until the captain written stories
a few decades ago that marvel actually
gave the main marvel comics universe a
numerical designation that came in the
form of
earth 616. the numerical designation for
the mcu
is 199 999 and it's actually based off
two universes in marvel comics the first
one is earth 1610 which you guys might
know is the ultimate universe it was
essentially an answer to the question in
the year 2000 what would it look like if
superheroes literally existed in the
world outside your window
the other universe is earth 98 which
doesn't really have a cool name like the
ultimate universe but it's basically an
alternate reality where superheroes age
in real time so let's break universes
down in the simplest of forms
you guys already know that you have
planets and stars and galaxies we don't
need to run over that but what you do
have are things called pocket dimensions
these are places like asgard where the
asgardians dwell
olympia where you have zeus and hera and
the other greek gods the crimson cosmos
where you have the demon entity sidorak
now there's only three ways to get to
these pocket dimensions the first is to
use a transportation or teleportation
device inherent to that pocket dimension
if you look at asgard for example you've
got the bifrost the second way to do it
is to use
magic doctor strange does that the third
way to do it is to alter reality in such
a way to where you can basically create
a portal to get to those realms that's
what scarlet witch can do but barring
those three ways there's no other
conceivable way to get to those
particular dimensions even when the
fantastic four are using technology
they're still using it to open portals
so let's expand this out
outside of these individual universes
every other universe is essentially the
same way every universe has its own
asgard every universe has its own
dormammu every universe has its own
sidorak and so on and so forth all the
cosmic entities that exist there every
universe has its own version of thanos
it just kind of repeats itself they just
take different forms depending on the
circumstance the ultimate universe had a
version of asgard and thor and odin and
loki and all those characters that were
more in line with real world norwegian
mythos but while each one of these
universes functions in its own way
you've also got organizations out there
who exist to make sure the universe
functions the way it's supposed to
if every universe comes into existence
by way of alterations to the time stream
then the job of the time variance
authority which we'll see on loki
actually exists to make sure that people
don't change the timeline so loki
doesn't go back in time
and then make sure he succeeds in
defeating all the avengers on earth in
the original avengers film
if he did that it would create an
alternate reality and while one person
doing that isn't necessarily a problem
if you have
a multiverse consisting of infinitely
expanding universes and at least
one person in every single one of those
universes decides to go and change time
suddenly it becomes an absolute
nightmare to try to manage and the whole
multiverse just
spirals out of control so the tva makes
sure that nobody ever really does that
what you also have here is you have
the omniversal development court if the
main marvel universe has the avengers
and the x-men of the fantastic four and
spider-man and all those different
heroes that all kind of came to fruition
somewhere along the line the omniversal
development court exists to make sure
that every universe does that so every
universe has its avengers and it has its
x-men and it has a spider-man and so on
and so forth in the case that they come
across a universe where that doesn't
exist
they initiate something called the push
and the push basically jump starts the
evolution of humanity to make sure that
mutant genes are activated a really good
example of them doing this and it
actually going horribly awry
was during the crooked world storyline
when they went to an alternate reality
called earth 238 and they realized
there's no superheroes here so they
initiated the push to create superheroes
a guy by the name of mad jim jaspers who
had the ability to alter reality on a
universal scale and was the reason why
no superheroes existed in that universe
because he basically killed them all
got pissed he initiated the jasper's
wharf which totally twisted and skewed
that universe and the only way to stop
him was to destroy his universe
now let's switch over to the marvel
cinematic universe for a second by all
standards of measurement from what we've
seen the marvel cinematic universe seems
to effectively have this same thing you
don't really see beings like sidorak
because sidorak
existed as an x-men property first
before he was a doctor strange character
and basically all the x-men stuff
belonged to fox not anymore disney owns
it all so you'll likely see sidorak
going forward but the character of
dormammu is where things become
particularly interesting and the reason
why is because in the marvel cinematic
universe unlike in marvel comics
dormammu does not exist in a pocket
dimension that exists in a singular
universe
dormammu exists in an entire universe
unto himself marvel has yet to
consolidate the difference between the
mcu version of dormammu and the version
that we know in comics at the end of the
day
it doesn't really matter all that much
he rules an entire universe and probably
a few other dimensions around that
universe that he calls the dark
dimension
the big difference between the dark
dimension and the marvel cinematic
universe and the dark dimension in
marvel comics is that in marvel comics
the dark dimension is actually a smaller
section of a plane of existence that at
one point was a much bigger section
what happened we don't know all we know
is that somewhere along the line that
dimension
fractured and it broke off into smaller
dimensions they became known as the
splinter realms which is where you get
guys like mephisto
nightmare the hell lords and the
nightmare lords dream lords as some
people call them in the marvel cinematic
universe
it's not that way seemingly dormammu
came into existence somewhere along the
line and instead of the dark dimension
fracturing off into smaller dimensions
instead he conquered the entirety of the
universe and then he subjugated all the
other realms around him basically
meaning that beings that we would
normally assume to be mephisto nightmare
people like that if they do exist in the
mcu and there's no reason to believe
they don't they all basically exist at
the pleasure of dormammu whether they're
actually servants or not we don't
necessarily know it could be one of
these things where dermous like the
president of his realm
and the other people are basically
governors kind of ruling their own
little sections
we don't really know we haven't been
given an explanation of how that whole
hierarchical structure works in the
marvel cinematic universe so back to our
main question
why is the multiverse falling apart in
spider-man far from home and presumably
going into doctor strange 2 which
explains the multiverse of madness but
what's really going on here is that if
that really is the case then all we're
really seeing is the multiverse falling
apart
as it refers to spider-man and really
nobody else it may very well be one of
these things
this is how they're explaining how the
x-men and the fantastic four are going
to end up in the mcu that they already
exist in other universes but because
it's all kind of falling apart that
they're basically going to end up in the
marvel cinematic universe
this is what we call a multiversal
collapse it took place in 2015 with
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers followed by secret wars
if you've never read those stories check
the description you'll find the whole
playlist down below the important thing
here is that what separates each
individual universe is a relatively thin
energy membrane and you can actually
bypass this membrane depending on what
kind of abilities you have it's much
like trying to access a pocket dimension
only somebody of sufficient energy
somebody like doctor strange somebody
like the scarlet witch can actually
bypass this membrane and just
walk right into an alternate reality if
you were able to do that it would quite
literally look like you were passing
through an invisible wall
and what you see is completely different
so say for example that in spider-man no
way home that the multiverse really is
falling apart and you have a kind of
coming together of different universes
you would see spider-man
walking down the street he would turn a
corner and he would pass what looks like
a thin wall and end up in a completely
different version of new york or maybe
there's hovering cars or something along
those lines that's basically how it
would look to you
you wouldn't realize what was going on
until you looked back and saw what was
basically a portal or you walked back
through that membrane again
but it's basically invisible to the
naked eye only people like doctor
strange that have the ability to cast
spells
to reveal this actual membrane would
know that it's there but the reason why
it's all falling apart
i think is because of wanda maximoff the
one to maximoff having taken on the role
of the scarlet witch in the marvel
cinematic universe in one division has
now been elevated to a multiversal
character
we know that for two reasons one because
she's going to be in the multiverse of
madness and it really wouldn't make a
whole lot of sense to have a character
who's not a multiversal threat be in a
movie about the multiverse the other
reason is because marvel told us that
but the big thing about this is that
scarlet witch has for some reason or
another started messing with things
maybe it's because she's just jumping
from one universe to the next
looking for her kids who she basically
had to destroy at the end of juan
division hoping they're alive in some
alternate reality where maybe she
doesn't exist
she can adopt them and then live happily
ever after maybe she's being tricked and
used by some kind of energy source out
there mephisto
nightmare dormammu who really knows for
certain but i think scarlet witch is the
reason why all it's happening and i
think what's going to happen here at the
end of doctor strange 2 and how it's all
going to completely change the stage for
the marvel cinematic universe as you're
basically going to see
a multiversal collapse you're going to
see a handful of realities that survive
being destroyed during the events of
doctor strange 2. those realities that
do survive are going to be merged into a
singular new universe and you're going
to get the x-men the fantastic four
probably some spider-man villains the
ones they care enough to keep and it's
going to bring venom into the mcu
that's my thought that's my theory let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section and i will catch you
all later
peace